Вітаю! Мене звати Артур Бабенко.
І сьогодні ми продовжимо
вивчати Історію України у 9-му класі
Тема нашого заняття буде
Політизація українського національного
руху в 90-тих роках ХІХ століття.
Дивимось на екран.
Про що ми сьогодні будемо говорити?
В першу чергу ми дізнаємось, як
українці створили перші політичні партії,
навіщо це вони зробили, хто це був.
Як вони боролись, створюючи політичні
партії, за інтереси і права українців.
Давайте ми пригадаємо попереднє заняття,
бо кожна з тем, яку ми проходимо з
вами, залежить одна від одної.
На минулому занятті ми говорили про досить
бурхливу діяльність двох основних течій
на території західноукраїнських земель.
Це течія москвофільська
і течія народовська.
Нагадаю, що москвофіли
основну свою ідею вибачали в тому,
що українському народу треба
об`єднатися з царською Росією і
– нібито цар прийде і порядок наведе.
Але власне стало зрозумілим, що
навряд чи хтось прийде і буде наводити
порядок, особливо якщо це стосується Росії.
Тому москвофільська течія, яка
спочатку була дуже популярною,
поступово почала, особливо до
90-х років ХІХ століття, згасати.
В той же час у 70-х роках ХІХ
століття виникає і проукраїнська течія,
яка починає поступово
набирати популярність.
Основою проукраїнської течії були,
звісно, народовці, або українофіли.
От якраз народовці і намагалися
захищати ось ту українську ідею,
ідею поширення української
мови, української культури
і згодом вже навіть ідею боротьби
за автономію Української Держави.
І сьогодні ми будемо говорити власне
про еволюцію поглядів народовців.
Власне, коли частина народовців зрозуміла,
що балачки балачками, але треба вже
намагатись діяти політичними методами.
Тобто частина зрозуміла, що
написання книжок, видавництво газет
і поширення певної інформації
– це лише половина діла.
Дуже важливо почати
боротися політичними методами,
а для цього треба
створювати політичні партії.
І власне про те, як вони
були створені, зараз піде мова.
Давайте спочатку з вами
пригадаємо – що таке політична партія?
Спробуйте спочатку подумати ви самостійно.
А я вам зараз нагадаю.
Політична партія – це певна
організація, сукупність людей,
яка має на меті отримати владу для
того, щоб реалізувати свої певні ідеї.
Тому, коли ми з вами говоримо
про українські політичні партії,
ми маємо на увазі якраз
створення тих організацій,
які мали на меті отримати певну
частину влади в різних органах
державної влади, і таким чином
боротися за права та інтереси українців.
І власне політичні ідеї дуже поширюються
саме у другій половині ХІХ століття.
Виникають різноманітні рухи в Європі.
Виникають різноманітні ідеї і ці ідеї
в тому числі впливають на українців,
як західноукраїнських земель,
так і Наддніпрянської України.
А для Наддніпрянської України
існували дуже великі перешкоди,
зокрема це Валуєвський циркуляр
1863 року, Емський указ 1876 року.
Ці всі закони, які були прийняті в Росії,
вони дуже обмежували
діяльність наддніпрянців.
Тому досить значна частина інтелігенції
переїжджає на територію
Західноукраїнських земель.
Зокрема це зробив вже
відомий вам діяч Драгоманов.
Він, приїхавши на територію
Західноукраїнських земель,
почав там поширювати свої ідеї,
він друкує, в тому числі,
й журнал «Громада».
Він починає спілкуватися з
молодими українцями-ідеалістами
на території західноукраїнських земель.
Він дуже сильно вплинув на таких
людей, як Михайло Павлік та Іван Франко.
Зокрема він їм казав, що треба
приступати вже до політичної боротьби.
Треба не тільки словами, але й ділом
боротись за розширення прав як
українського народу, так і взагалі України.
До речі, нагадаю вам, що Драгоманов
бачив майбутнє України як Держави
у складі федерації –
федерації слов`янських народів.
Ця ідея федерації слов`янських
народів була дуже давньою,
її ще відстоювали кирило-мефодіївці, і в
ХІХ столітті вона була досить поширеною.
Зокрема Михайло Павлік і Іван Франко
спочатку намагалися відстоювати такі ідеї.
Якраз завдяки Драгоманову
і завдяки такій мотивації
– шукати політичні шляхи,
Михайло Павлік та Іван Франко
вирішують об`єднатись.
Вони один одного знали по
спільній праці в журналі «Друг»,
вони працювали в цьому
журналі в 70-ті роки.
І кожен з них був дуже
талановитим і незаурядним.
Дивимось на екран.
Я вам зараз покажу, якщо ви не
пам`ятаєте, як вони виглядають.
Ми бачимо ліворуч Михайла
Павліка, а праворуч Івана Франка.
Трошки розкажу про кожного з них.
Іван Франко, ви його звісно знаєте
як відомого українського письменника
і активного суспільного діяча. Але
хто він такий і звідки він з`явився?
Іван Франко народився в родині
звичайного коваля, але досить заможного.
Також його мати походить з
давнього роду Скоропадського.
І власне Іван Франко ще з дитинства
відрізнявся своєю феноменальною пам’яттю.
Переповідали, що коли
він слухав якісь лекції,
то він їх міг просто досконало відтворити.
Більш того, він був надзвичайно
талановитим гуманітарієм
і звісно почав працювати
саме в цьому напрямку.
Він вивчив приблизно
14 мов, деякі кажуть 17.
Вищу освіту здобув якраз
у Львівському Університеті,
вмів досконало писати як польською,
так і німецькою мовами і
володів ними як і українською.
Він був людиною надзвичайно продуктивною.
Зокрема він кожних два
дні писав той чи інший твір.
Писав він на різноманітні
тематики: вірші, прозові твори.
Зокрема цікавився також
різноманітними течіями,
маю на увазі сферами діяльності
– це історія, етнографія, культура.
Він був людиною різнобічною.
Також Іван Франко не боявся
висловлювати свою точку зору,
інколи через це у нього
виникали конфлікти.
Зокрема був випадок, коли один з
поляків навіть вчинив замах на його життя,
але слава Богу не успішний.
Відповідно Франко, який також дуже активно
боровся за розвиток української культури,
за розширення прав українців, дуже
схвально сприйняв ідеї Драгоманова
і вирішив їх втілити в життя.
Але, звісно, самостійно
він це зробити не міг.
Тому одним з його найближчих
товаришів-компаньйонів
був якраз Михайло Павлік.
Був також надзвичайно завзятий,
надзвичайно ідейний українець,
який вивчившись, зрозумів, що
боротьба за українську культуру,
українську ідею є також
основою його життя.
І от, об`єднавшись вдвох,
залучивши своїх товаришів,
тому що не тільки вдвох вони це
зробили, Франко і Павлік утворили
першу в історії України політичну партію.
І ця партія ввійшла в історію під назвою
Русько-українська радикальна партія (РУРП).
Рік утворення цієї партії – 1890.
Тобто саме в цьому році, виникла
перша в історії України політичні сила.
Зазвичай політичні партії
мають певну ідеологію.
Русько-українська радикальна
партія була не виключення.
Основна ідеологія цієї
політичної сили – це був соціалізм.
Тоді соціалізм по всій
території Європи був трендовим.
Це була ідея, яку намагались сповідувати,
якої намагались дотримуватись багато
різних політичних сил в багатьох країнах.
Ви вже вивчали з Всесвітньої історії
поширення політичних ідей в ХІХ столітті.
Але давайте я вам нагадаю,
що ж таке соціалізм.
Соціалізм – це політична ідея того,
що всі люди повинні бути рівними.
Причинами виникнення цієї
ідеї було те, що в ХІХ столітті
велика кількість людей отримувала
не те, на що вони були достойні.
Що я маю на увазі? Наприклад,
робітники, коли працювали на заводах,
отримували мізерну заробітну
платню, працювали в надважких умовах.
Більшість прибутків, звісно,
йшли власникам цих заводів,
тобто це буржуазія або капіталісти.
Селяни також в багатьох
країнах, зокрема і в Україні
– це була гостра проблема, були
безземельними або малоземельними.
І тому соціалізм був таким
благодатним ґрунтом для того,
щоб реалізувати ідеї рівності.
Зокрема, згідно соціалістичних
ідей, селяни повинні були,
як варіант, отримати
кожен рівну частину землі,
або створити певні колективні господарства
для того, щоб спільно працювати на
цих землях і спільно ділити прибуток.
Робітники повинні були бути
самі власниками цих заводів,
щоб прибуток з цих підприємств
вільно розподілявся між робітниками.
Ось власне такі ідеї рівності,
ідеї спільної власності,
ідеї спільного поділу - вони
були притаманними соціалізму.
Звісно це не все, але це та
основа, яку можна запам`ятати.
Ось такі ідеї і намагалися захищати,
або таких ідей намагались дотримуватись
представники Русько-української
радикальної партії.
Давайте в вами
проаналізуємо один уривочок.
В ньому якраз і сказано про ці основні ідеї
(дивимось на екран).
«… зрівняти всіх людей на світі
так, аби кожен на себе робив,
а не на других; аби кожний
мав чим і на чім робити…
Така наука про рівність всіх
людей називається соціалізм,
такі думки звуться соціалістичними, а
чоловік котрий їх тримається, - соціаліст,
по-нашому гуртівник, або товаришник, бо
все має йти на гурт товариствам, громадам».
От власне це як раз цитата
одного з керівників Русько-української
радикальної партії – це Павлік.
Він намагався пояснити
людям що ж таке соціалізм.
Зокрема, реалізуючи ось саме ці ідеї,
лідери Русько-української радикальної партії
виступали за те, щоб передати всю
власність, зокрема і земельну власність,
до громад для того, щоб
не було соціальної нерівності,
тобто не було перегибів в плані
бідних людей і багатих людей.
Соціалісти намагалися відтворити,
в їхньому баченні, справедливий лад.
Русько-українська радикальна партія
орієнтувалася, в першу чергу, на селянство.
І це не дивно, бо якщо
подивитись на соціальні стани
на території західноукраїнських
земель, то видно, що більшість населення,
особливо українського
населення, вони проживали в селах.
І основа економіки на
західноукраїнських територіях,
та і взагалі всієї території України
– це було сільське господарство.
В промисловості було
задіяно приблизно 2% людей.
Тому відповідно наймасштабніший
електорат був саме на території села
і найбільша кількість знедолених
людей, які потребували захисту їх прав,
знаходились в сільській місцевості.
Власне для того, щоб агітувати,
для того щоб поширювати свої ідеї,
були створені різноманітні осередки
Русько-української радикальної партії.
Ця партія займалась тим, що
створювала фонди, просвітницькі установи.
Франко писав різноманітні
відозви до селян.
Але мушу сказати, що їхні ідеї
не набули широкого поширення.
Можливо через те, що для
селян це було надто важко.
Можливо через те, що
в їхніх ідеях містилось
багато інформації, яку
селяни просто не сприйняли.
Але суть полягає в то, що ця партія
не набула величезної популярності.
Але значення цієї
партії полягає в тому, що
завдяки її існуванню, українці набувають
досвіду політичної боротьби,
політичної діяльності.
Ця партія не була однорідною.
До цієї партії приєдналось
відомих, на той момент,
представників української
інтелігенції і умовно
можна поділити членів цієї
партії на два угрупування.
Це напрямок більш консервативний,
його представляв Франко,
Павлік, Будзиновський, Данилович.
І також це нова течія, його представляли
здебільшого Бачинський, Терлецькій та інші.
Що дуже важливо.
В 1895 році відбувся
четвертий з`їзд цієї партії,
якраз це був канун Нового
року, це було 30 грудня 1895 року.
І на цьому з`їзді виступив один
з представників цієї молодої течії,
його звали Юліан Бачинський. Він
ще до цього з`їзду написав брошуру,
яка називається «Україна
irredenta» або «Україна уярмлена»,
обкладинку цієї брошури
ви бачите на екрані.
Що було дуже важливого в цій книзі?
В цій книзі він вперше в історії
України обґрунтував ідею боротьби
за українську самостійність,
тобто за українську незалежність.
Тобто вперше ці ідеї боротьби за
незалежність лягли в основу певної програми.
Цю книжку ще до четвертого
з`їзду читав Франко.
Але, я вам нагадаю, від був
прихильником спочатку Драгоманівських ідей
щодо створення федерації слов`янських
народів і щоб Україна ввійшла,
як одна з країн до цієї федерації.
Франко спочатку
відкинув ідею цієї брошури.
Але Юліан Бачинський був тим
молодим українським націоналістом,
який вважав, що треба захищати
свої ідеї, і треба йти до кінця.
Зрозумівши, що Франко його
в даному питанні проігнорував,
він вирішив оприлюднити свою
брошуру якраз на одному із з`їздів.
І ось 30 грудня 1895 року
трапилась така нагода.
Спочатку були доповіді
інших членів партії.
Але потім виступив Юліан Бачинський і
прочитав основні ідеї із своєю брошури.
Спочатку до цього
віднеслись дуже стримано.
Деякі, особливо консервативна течія
Русько-української радикальної партії,
говорили, що дуже
передчасні ідеї, треба почекати.
Треба спочатку боротись,
принаймні, за українську автономію,
а вже потім можна
думати і про незалежність.
Але більш того, частина казали, що
давайте запитаємо і представників
Наддніпрянської України.
Бо все ж таки Україна єдина -
і Західна, і Наддніпрянська.
Але Юліан Бачинський
сказав - навіщо нам чекати,
давайте ставити максимальні
цілі і власне їх досягати.
І завдяки тому, що він дуже
активно підтримав цю ідею,
він настільки емоційно
висловився на захист своїх поглядів,
що його виступ зустріли бурхливими
оплесками і ідеї цієї брошури
лягли в програму
Русько-української радикальної партії.
Це відбулося якраз в 1895 році.
Тому який висновок ми можемо зробити?
Це була
Русько-українська радикальна партія,
це була не тільки перша партія
в історії України, але це була
перша партія, яка проголосила ідею боротьби
за незалежну, самостійну державність.
І знову ж таки завдяки активній діяльності
Юліана Бачинського і його
книзі «Україна уярмлена».
Саме в цій брошурі вперше пролунала
ідея боротьби за самостійну Україну.
Ця партія розвивається. Ця
партія намагається знайти свій шлях.
А поки ця партія шукає свій
шлях, ми повинні поговорити з вами
ще про одну дуже важливу подію,
яка відбулася також в 1890 році,
тобто в тому ж році, коли виникла
Русько-українська радикальна партія.
Ця подія називається «Нова ера»
в україно-польських відносинах.
Дивимось на екран.
Період «Нової ери» був достатньо важливим,
хоча зараз його певним чином недооцінюють.
Ми з вами зараз дізнаємось, що ж це
за період і що важливого в нього було.
Ви на екрані бачите, що назва «Нова
ера» у польсько-українських відносинах,
тобто це зрозуміло, що це щось, що
настало між українцями і поляками.
Це, щоб казати простою
мовою, пошук компромісу,
тобто пошук діалогу між
українським населенням і польським.
Ви вже знаєте, що на території
Галичини були дуже складні
взаємовідносини між українцями і поляками,
бо поляки вважали всю
територію Галичини своєю.
Хоча переважна кількість поляків жила в
західній Галичині, з центром місто Краків.
Але вони казали, що вся Галичина повинна
знаходитись під польським контролем.
В той же час велика частина
українців казала, що ні,
стривайте – на Східній Галичині
здебільшого проживають українці.
Українці здебільшого
проживають в сільській місцевості,
але все одно українців більше,
українська культура більше поширена
і от ті українці, які намагалися отримати
вплив на території Східної Галичини,
вони боролися проти польського впливу.
Цей конфлікт був досить гострим
протягом всього ХІХ століття.
Але в 1890 роках саме австрійська влада
виступила з ініціативою порозуміння
між поляками та українцями.
У вас може виникнути питання:
«А чому саме 1890 рік і
чому саме австрійці?».
Відповідь дуже проста. В цей час Австрія
намагається поступово знайти контакти,
і знаходить їх, з Німеччиною (тоді
Німеччина перетворилась на потужну імперію)
і згодом Австрія приєднається разом
з Німеччиною до Троїстого союзу,
і, звісно, це зближення
Австрії і Німеччини
влипнуло на відносини Австрії
і Російської імперії в гірший бік, звісно.
І от австрійці зрозуміли, що у випадку
погіршення відносин, у випадку конфлікту,
Росія може використати українців
Галичини в своїх інтересах.
Тому для того, щоб цього не було,
австрійці вирішили випередити
можливий певний конфлікт,
і для цього вони вирішили
задобрити українців,
і показати, що австрійська
влада підтримує український рух.
І тому австрійці виступили з ініціативою
бути посередниками у цьому діалозі
і частина українців-народовців сказали,
що дійсно треба шукати цей діалог.
Дивимось на екран.
Період «Нової ери» тривав чотири роки.
Нажаль, не було створено такого
комплексного документу, щодо того,
щоб розробити певні правила взаємодії.
Тим не менш, за цей час вдалося
відкрити кафедру історії України
у Львівському університеті, і я
вам нагадаю, що очолив цю кафедру
саме Михайло Сергійович Грушевський.
Завдяки його переїзду на
територію Західноукраїнських земель,
в тому числі, активно розвивалася наука,
тому що він згодом очолив НТШ
(Наукове товариство ім. Шевченка).
До речі пригадайте – коли
виникло це товариство.
Також поступово було створено
страхове товариство «Дністер»,
яке допомагало в тому числі
селянам, в фінансовому плані.
Більш активного поширення
набула українська мова і в школах,
і в вищих навчальних закладах. Хоча, знову
ж таки, казати про вищі навчальні заклади,
то там переважно була
польська мова на той момент.
Але тим не менш, ця політика «Нової
ери» дала свої плоди, не максимальні.
Звісно, це не те, що вдалося
максимально реалізувати.
Але тим не менш, певні
позитивні кроки вже були.
Тому завдяки цьому, хоча б на трошки,
українці просунулись вперед в
захисті своїх прав та інтересів.
Ну а ми знов переходимо до партій.
Ви вже знаєте, що першою
партією на Західноукраїнських землях
була Русько-українська радикальна партія.
Але, оскільки це була перша партія,
вона ще не сформувала певної
чіткої стратегії свого розвитку.
Всередині цієї партії було
багато різноманітних течій.
Я вам казав, що з цих течій
вирізнялися дві основні –
це консервативна і більш
така молода – радикальна.
Поступово між членами партії
виникали світоглядні конфлікти.
Одні хотіли рухатися одним
напрямком, інші – іншим.
І цей конфлікт привів до розколу
Русько-української
радикальної партії в 1899 році.
Партія розкололась на дві політичні сили.
Перша політична сила – Українська
соціал-демократична партія.
Дивимось на дошку
Її очолили як раз такі молоді
більш радикальні українці,
зокрема Бачинський, Ганкевич та інші.
І друга течія – це Українська
національно-демократична партія (УНДП).
Що дуже важливо - більш
популярною була, все ж таки,
Українська національно-демократична
партія (УНДП).
До неї ввійшли як раз більш такі
помірковувані, консервативні члени РУРП.
Але між цими напрямками
було дуже багато спільного
і що важливо запам`ятати – спільною була
кінцева мета діяльності цих двох партій,
а саме боротьба за
самостійну і незалежну Україну.
Але яким чином могли боротись українці,
де вони могли отримати
владу і що вони могли зробити?
Загалом політична діяльність українців
була можливою у наступних органах.
Дивимось на екран.
Перший орган
– це Австрійський парламент,
який називався Державною Радою.
І Галицький сейм, а
також Буковинський сейм.
До речі в Австрії в 1867
році відбулась реформа.
Австрія перетворилася
на Австро-Угорську імперію
і існували парламенти, як в
Австрії, так і в Угорщині.
Але нас більше цікавить
саме Австрійський парламент,
який знаходився у Відні,
називався Державна Рада.
Туди українцям обиратися було надзвичайно
складно, але такої мети на початку і не було.
Бажано було обиратися до місцевого сейму,
саме до Галицького сейму,
який знаходився в м.Львів.
На екрані видно будівлю,
де розташовувався цей сейм.
Вибори в Галицький сейм
проходили кожні 6 років,
але на жаль, через те, що в українців
ще не було досвіду політичної боротьби,
вони під час виборів дуже
часто програвали полякам.
Відповідно результат був дуже низьким,
зокрема із 150 членів сейму представників
українського народу було, приблизно, 16-20.
Це було пов`язано ще і з тим, що велика
частина українців не мали право голосу,
в порівнянні з тими самими поляками.
Тому, як ви бачите, спочатку
можливості політичної діяльності
в різних владних установах
були вкрай низькими.
Але українці не розчаровувалися.
Вони продовжували боротися,
щоб розширити кількість людей,
які могли б брати участь в виборах.
Вони боролись за те, щоб
увійти до цього парламенту,
навіть по одному, по двоє, по троє.
Але це вже був певний результат.
Ті українці, які були членами сейму,
намагалися використовувати
парламентську трибуну як раз для того,
щоб поширювати свої
ідеї, захищати певні права.
Це були перші кроки, але вони
згодом приведуть до певних результатів.
Про ці результати ви
дізнаєтесь на наступних уроках.
Ну а сьогодні в нас все.
І давайте зробимо підсумок
уроку, про що ми сьогодні дізнались.
В першу чергу – ми дізнались
з вами про виникнення
першої політичної партії,
Русько-української.
Ми дізнались про те,
що саме в це час виникла
і почалась реалізовуватись ідея боротьби за
українську самостійність, або незалежність
і автором цієї ідеї був Юліан Бачинський.
Ми з вами дізнались про те,
що можливість цієї політичної боротьби
була, хоча і мінімальна, але тим не менше.
І цю можливість намагалися
використовувати сповна.
Дякую за увагу.
Але перед завершенням
давайте закріпимо матеріал.
Я вам дам декілька питань, а
ви спробуєте на них відповісти.
Питання на екрані.